we're desperate to avoid it of course
but we won't for a lot of very good
reasons firstly we don't understand
ourselves were all crazy in very
particular ways in neurotic unbalanced
and immature but we don't know the
details because no one encourages us too
hard to find out our friends just want
to be kind and have fun with us our
enemies don't want to waste the trouble
so we end up with such a poor level of
self understanding we have no clue of
who we be compatible with a standard
question on any early dinner date should
simply be how are you mad but it's so
hard to know secondly we don't
understand other people it is hard to
work out the craziness of other people
as it is our own they put on such a good
show at first what we die dearly need is
to send them and us through a battery of
psychological questionnaires and have
four years of intensive psychotherapy
individuals and couples based before
reaching a decision by 2100 this will no
longer sound like a joke people will
merely wonder why took humanity so long
to get us here the answer used to being
happy we think we want happiness but
what we really want is what we used and
that usually doesn't involve too much
happiness at all growing up most of us
had our love mixed in with other darker
stuff being controlled feeling
humiliated being abandoned or abused in
short suffering and now whatever we may
say that's what we mostly still on the
lookout for it explains why we rejected
all those candidates the well-balanced
mature reliable ones are somehow a bit
boring and why we had instead secret
energy to those characters we
unconsciously know will mess us up in
such cozily familiar ways
being single is so awful you have to be
very at peace with empty Saturday
evenings constant alienation and
sexlessness in order to be choosy in the
right way no wonder most of us just
partially shut our eyes
crapples instinct has too much prestige
marriage used to be a rational business
all to do with your parents matching
their bit of land with the neighbors it
was horribly cold and calculating so now
we have romantic marriages it's meant to
be all about how you feel you should
never think too much to analyze the
decision immediately feels unromantic
indeed the most romantic thing to do may
just be to propose really suddenly
perhaps after only a few weeks in a
chapel in Vegas at 3 a.m. the madness
seems a paradoxical sign that the
marriage itself will be a sensible idea
it won't be since we don't go to schools
of love we don't have any information we
don't take classes we don't talk to
married couples and we steer very clear
of divorced ones so we go into it
without knowing why marriage is really
fail beyond what we take to be just the
simple stupidity of all those other
couples we're not like at all freezing
happiness you want to make nice things
permanent you're in Venice on the lagoon
with no responsibilities The Evening Sun
throwing gold flakes across the sea the
prospect of dinner and little fish
restaurant and your beloved in a
cashmere jumper in your arms you get
married to make that feeling permanent
but it all goes and what is really
permanent is the partner but now in a
very different mood Nate you want to
stop thinking about love it's such a
pain the heartache but dating the
one-night stands you want shot of it all
you marry to stop having to think about
love all the time all of which is why
you'll marry the wrong person or perhaps
have done so already but it's not really
your fault
no one ever teaches us how to do this
thing and so of course we crash we will
as a species eventually learn that
hairless madness can't go on too many
people get hurt in a few centuries at
least we'll be getting the hang of it
for sure
[Music]